はいみなさんこんにちは
ていません
先ほど離された土井先生はまあ宇宙に行った事がある人ですけれども私はあの
望遠鏡を使ったりあるいは物理学の理論を使ったりして家のことを見ているしたことを
調べている天文学者です
同時になあの先ほど土井先生もあの紹介されませんけれども
あの兄弟の中でですね宇宙ユニットといって
文系まで含めて幅広い学問を総合して
家のことを色々考えてみようというそういうあの員との質も長いこと参加してまして
今日私が話しするのは私の専門のテーマが来てより私がこう何年か
人文系の先生方と一緒に開拓してきた新しい家の学問のことをご紹介したいと思い
ます
この写真ですねずいぶん古い写真見えますけどもこれは太平洋戦争前ですね1940年
前後にあの京都大学の花山天文台で行われた一般公開の写真ですあの着物姿紋別方の
人々が望遠鏡3というのが見えますね
でまぁあの遥か昔からですね人間まあ宇宙に興味を持ってきたわけですそして宇宙に
憧れを持って好奇心をもってまあうちのことを知りたいと思ってきた
私もあの
宇宙に興味を持ってても楽団たわけですけども
なんで人が宇宙に惹かれるのかという話を大事にしたいと思います
この前に野皆さんお見せしているのはあの紫外線で見た対応ですねこれ本当の対応の
写真ですさあの紫外線ですけどえーっとここにちっちゃく地球がありますね大体これが
の大きさになります1はもっとほんと多いですけど
太陽地球の100倍捉えれば大きなほしいです
実はですねまああの
世の中にはですねこの宇宙にはもっと大きな星がありますこれは正規巨
赤色巨星というですねあの真っ赤ですごく大きなことですこれ本当に8説教調整の写真
みてるわけじゃなくてこれぐらい大きいのってを説明するためにですねここに退位を
置いて
地球なくがおきたいよーがー
こういうふうに起きたとするとこんなに大きな星や
まあ世の中にはいっぱいのですね私子供の頃にあのこの赤色巨星の8まあ
ことを絵本で読んで
世の中にこんなでかいものがあるのかと
それは
ワクワク感とよりは半分以上は恐怖だったんですよね恐ろしいと思いました
怖いけども恐ろしいこのポアさとワクワク感の入り混じったような
世界にすごく惹かれてうちのこと好きになりました
私あの兄弟以外にですねあのちょっと精華大学っていうあの芸大位でも8授業してるん
ですけども
そこでは芸術を学ぶ学生さんですね家のことがめっちゃ好きなんですっていう人が言い
ました
で
あなたが
宇宙のことに触れるときに感じる感動は他のどういう時に感じる感動にてますかって
その人に聞いたですね
彼女はしばらく答えてですね足場等考えて
めっちゃ変わったヘッジの人を見たときと
答えました皆さん意味わかりますか僕はすごくよく分かりましたこれは僕にとっての
積極調査と一緒なんです
つまりー
自分の理解を超えた存在自分の日常感覚超えた存在
自分の知っている世界ではない世界でもそれが本当にそこにあるんだっていうことに
対する感動なんですね
自分の知っている世界だけは世界だけじゃなくて自分が全く知らない世界がでもそこに
あるっていう
この世界に対する憧れというか
恭文混じるかも知れませんか
そういうものが
あの
宇宙の魅力だと僕は思っています
であのな軍師と話せこの子だけなんですけども
私これはあの
そういう中でですね人文社会系の学問をする意味やどこになるのかという話をするとき
によく紹介する話です
あの私の言及がなくてあの信州大学森山徹さんというですね動物行動学者の方がですね
あのダンゴムシに心はあるのかっていう本を書いてあります森山さんはどういう研究者
かというとですね
ダンゴムシて不思議な性質があってて右左右左て交互に曲がるんですね障害物に
ぶつかることまあそれはその方が逃げるのに有利なんですけれどもそれはある4番ゴム
死ぬ
の小さな小さな神経細胞の中に刻み込まれた本能なようなもんだとみんな思っている
わけです
森山さんは何をしたかというとですねその団子虫用
ある迷路の中に入れたそのメールはですねあの自動的にクルクルクルクル回せるように
なっていてずーっとダンゴムシが右左右されて曲がると同じとこずーっと行った行っ
たり次になっているそういう仕掛けがあるんです
そして彼は何を発見したかというとダンゴムシはですね
何十回が入ったり入ったりを繰り返すと切れます
向き it なって壁を登り出したりぐるぐる回り出したり右右に入ってもらったり今
までしなかった彼らの本能じゃないと生まれた振る舞いをします
で森山さんはそれをダンゴムシの隠された心だと
つまり単調作業に耐えられなくなる彼らには心があるんだと
まあそういうふうに言われるわけですね
まあ
これ本当に心と呼ぶかどうかはまあそれは解釈がいろいろあると思いますから置いて
おきましょうでも大事なことはこの団子虫の知られざる性質は自然の中で団子虫を観察
しても誰もわからなかった
そうじゃなくてダンゴムシ的にありえない新しい環境に置いたからこそその団子虫の
知られざる政府が見えてきたわけです
つまりある対象をその対象にとってまったく新しい世界で非常に極端に異なる世界
新しい環境そういうところに置いてあるとそのお金が対象の今まで知られていなかった
性質が明らかになることがある
というわけであの宇宙は
人間とっての
新しい環境ですつまり団子虫の新しいしられなかった心が開いた買った心が
迷路の中で見出されたように人間が宇宙に行くことで人間もしかその人間の集団が
つくる社会
それらの今まで知られてなかったフェイスが明らかになるかもしれない
そして僕自身がその天体のことを知りたいと思って宇宙のことを知りデータ持って天文
学者だったように人間のことをしていたい
人間が作る社会について知りたいと思ってその好奇心に各課の駆動された学問というの
は人文社会系の学問ですよね
つまり人間のことを知りたい社会のことを知りたいと思っている人文社会系の学校に
とってこそ
人間が宇宙に
行き始めた今宇宙はそれらの学問のフィールドに
なりつつあるわけです
なので私は
ここ何年かいろんな
人文系の
研究者と一緒にジム車回転の研究者と一緒にあの宇宙と
なんとかがくみたいな研究をいっぱい
始めようとしてきました
装置の一つはですね倫理学と宇宙という分野です倫理学皆さんどんな学問か想像つき
ますかね
倫理つまり人間はどう振る舞うべきかどういうものに価値を見いだすのかそういうこと
に興味を持って探求している学問です哲学の一分野です
もちろん宇宙開発には様々な林問題がつきまといます例えばあの宇宙飛行士の安全は
どこまでへと確保されるべきであるかとか
それから
人工衛星のデータがですねどんどんどんどん解像度良くなっているとこのプライバシー
の問題があります
そのプライバシーの問題と衛星データが向上することにより利便性はどちらを優先さ
れる人がいろんなりん問題があります
まあそういう宇宙開発に伴う様々な倫理問題を解決するためにも倫理学が必要なんです
けども
でもっと大事なのはそれじゃないそうではなくて人間の倫理とはどういうものか人間は
どういうものに
価値を見いだしているのかどのように振る舞うべきなのかという倫理学が根源的な問題
について
宇宙という新しい環境が新たなしてをなりかけてくるわけです
例えば
我々は火星の環境今もしかしたら微生物住んでるかも知れませんけどまぁ砂漠見たとか
ですよねそれを我々が住みやすいように変えることはですねそう言って火星の環境破壊
なんじゃない
逆に我々人間がそういうこと非常に異なる環境に行く時に環境を変えられないなら我々
が変わるしか第一に生きていくためちゃう
例えば遺伝子工学や細胞技術にタイムを使って人間を改変することそれは今の地球では
もちろん倫理的に言うとレイヤーとしていますでもそれが火星とか他の天体という
新しい環境で生きてくために必要なことだとしたらその倫理の前提は変わるかもしれ
ない
そんな風に宇宙っていう全く異なる状況がですね
我々の
価値判断何をすべきだと言う
ことを考えをあの
前提となっているようなことですね
ひっくり返してくるそのことによって我々は倫理というもの対してより深く考えること
ができるわけです
そんなことを倫理が咲く一緒に行ったりしています
歴史研究者と一緒に研究もしています
私たちに天文学者として太陽のですね太陽活動タイム爆発がを研究してるんですけども
対応でバック後キュートな2月期におけるか
一番昔から起きることが知れてるのはオーロラです
で対応ですねあのどれくらい大きな爆発大きいの買っては誰たのどれくらい大きな地震
が起きるかと一緒ですねあのいろいろ面白いことなんですけども
なぜ近代感想が100年ぐらいか歴史がありませんでも昔から人々は庭園ペンチを記録
してきました
たとえばここに後ろに出しているアティヤですね江戸時代ぐらいですね
あの日本しかも京都ぐらいでもオーラが見えたんです京都でも
のオーラが見えたことあります1770年ですその時の日本中で見えたオールだの8柄
を合わせてますあのこれ
右上な本当の山の桜の写真ですけど
でですね当時はもちろん皆あの人1オーナーか知らなかったですね
なんかカジカとかなんか持ってこーやんねー水かけたりとかいろんなことをしています
で日本の記録だけじゃなくてたとえばあのバビロニアのですね
楔あの年度版に刻み込まれた楔形文字中にもオールはみたいな記録は残っていますそう
いう天文学弛めないけども歴史研究者たちで選んでる文献を読むことで我々は過去の
対応活動することができる
だから歴史文献がサイエンスに役立つ
それだけではなくて
こういう天変地異を見た時に人々がどのように反応してきたかということをつぶさに見
てやるとですね
例えば日本とか中国のが東アジアでですね
自然科学近代科学みたいなものがどんな風に人々の
考え方の中に根付いてきたかということの編成見ることができます昔は
天変はですね
空からのお告げだったわけですよ地上の政治が悪いから神様起こったみたいなそういう
ことをしている
だんだんだんだんです人々の記録はあの
客観的になってきたですねこれ確か100年前に起きた当時うちの子ちゃんがいて誰か
なーみたいなそんな傷が出てくるんです
だんだんだんだん人々が
名神の世界からカークの世界にあるいは宗教的な考え方から合理的な考え方に少しずつ
山遺跡の
これをかけることによりそれはどちらかというと歴史研究者のキョンデスまれ我は天文
学者と歴史研究者が一緒に研究することによって3 s 点もがのサイズが2つしそう
いう人間の考え方の歴史も同時に研究しています
宇宙人類学とになってます宇宙人の研究ではありません
人類が宇宙に行くそのことが人類に何をもたらすかという研究です
これ有名な写真ですねアポロ17号がとった地球の写真ですこの写真見て皆さんに思い
ますか
綺麗だなと思いますか
この写真はあの
まあアポロ計画とですねまぁいうなるは米そうの冷戦は軍事教祖の産物としてあった
宇宙のミッションがしかし
このスト宇宙から見たこの暗闇に浮かぶ青い星の写真を皆さん見せることによってあ
人類みな兄弟だなぁとこの上で殺しあうのあまりにバカバカしいということを教えて
くれた最中ですねでも同時にこの措置は別のことを訴え買っていきますここから出たら
切られないんじゃないかって閉塞感です
そう思いませんかここから出られないこんな小さな地球
我々は今グローバル化という名のもとに地球はどんどんどんどん狭くなってます
どんどんどんどん人々
一時も容易になってくるそしてコミュニケーションをようになってくるそれ我々何を
もたらすかそれはいいメモを垂らしますが
別の側面は文化の画一化均質化です
文化人類が者のレヴィストロースはこんな言葉を残します想像に満ちた偉大な時代とは
遠く離れたパートナーと刺激を与える程度に情報交換ができしかもその頻度と速度は
集団個人間に不可欠の壁を小さくすぎて
交換が容易になり画一化が進み対応生が見失われない程度にとどまっていた時代
すなわちエレ b ストロース文化人の方レヴィストロースを言ったり子
とは本当に人間がクリエイティブやるためには人間の間には人間の集団の間にはある種
の殻でつらいといけない
あまりにもコミュニケーションが容易になってしまう息が容易になってしまって
またにペットのコンセプトですアイディアず bose プレーティングは
地球全然普通とした結果みんなその愛では持っちゃったら何でつまらない世界だろう
でも今愛知球場はすごく狭くなってます8
交通手段の叩くとしてインターネット叩くによって非常にコミュニケーションが容易に
なっている
もう人間をクリエイティブなれないんじゃないかじゃあどうする
遠いとこに行ったらいいんじゃないと言っ
ちょっと無理やりですかねでも実際いこうとする人がいるわけです
加瀬20とかね他の天体に行こうとする人たちがうその過程に行こうと知るたちがね
あの
人類の多様性を止めて言ってるのかどうかは知りません
ですが
私自身は
人類が地球を出て
他の天体こと宇宙へ行くことは
地球のためになるとはなんとはあまり思えません
だけどもこの人類全体が
狭いところでどんどんどんどん分解考え方が確立するしてしまって
創造性をなくなってしまっているときにですね
まったく離れた環境によっおいて
我々地球の文明から孤立したある程度孤立した
ちょっとワイキキやるけどある程度プリズさ文明がそこんで弾いということはおそらく
人類のあなたの多様性のタネになるんじゃ
ないかと思っています
さあで多様性はみんな好きな言葉ですけど本当にうれしいのかその作用性を
もちろん
いろんなものがあればいいまあ一般にいいことですよね
だけどたとえばさっきリンリーのところいったように宇宙という極端が環境で
人々が住むとしたらそういうたちは遺伝子工学を使って体を作り変えるかもしれない
人間と人間じゃないものの間にそんなになるかも知れ
あるいは地球を出て行くな人たちはそもそも地球的なものが嫌で出てくるかもしれない
反地球的な考え方を持った集団としていくのかもしれない
倫理を前提が変わると言いましたリーンの前提が変わるということはそういう人たちは
違う倫理を持つかもしれないです
違う倫理を持った人というのは我々にとって良いと思う事いいと思わず悪いと思う事
いいと思うのかもしれない
そう優秀だができることは我々にとって幸せなのかというとそれ
微妙だなと思います
もう今から何十年前に生物学さんがホールデンさんはこんな言葉を残して舞う中という
のは我々が想像する以上に奇妙な所9か想像できる以上に奇妙なところなんだと
つまり宇宙で花開く人類の多様性というのはですね
なんかこうみんな違ってみんないいんがバラ色な世界ではなくておそらく今の我々に
とって気持ち悪い恐ろしいグロテスクな
そういう新たな存在が
宇宙できることだと思います
さあ皆さんそんな未来をほしいですか
万とも言えないですよね何とも言えないそのアンビバレンスこそが僕は打ち止め夜から
魅力だと思っています
別の人の言葉際ご紹介します兄弟のですねあのまあ人類学とか生態学者の有名な今西
錦司先生な言葉
今に先生が
内を語ったこんなことを残します私なんかは自分の一緒については自然が破壊されて
いくのを楽しんだりしている
けれども人間の一生を考えたらサイボーグでも何でもいいからもっともっと発展して
ほしいで気持ちいいんじゃないと
わかりますか
自分一人の1丁自分の身の回り自分の子供たち自分の友人等等いうことを考えたらです
ねやっぱり今の自然貝木の地球を守ってるりん理解
あまり変なことしたくない
だけども
自分ひとり1勝ではなくてこの宇宙に生まれた
人類としてあるいは生命として
この先どこまで人類がスープのわかりませんが
その人類がどこまで
発展というかですね
なにかを生み出すいるだろうかということを考えたときは今の我々の感覚からすれば
怖くて恐れ付で気持ち悪いもんだとしてもやっぱり遺伝子工学だろうがサイボーグ
だろうが
なんでもいいからどんどんどんどんいけいけどんどんで8点セット欲しいたいん
この2つの矛盾する考え方を同時にもすることを
今井先生おいてます
僕自身も同じことを感じます
この地球上でですね画一化された文化でずーっとこの地球上で
持続可能性をするな持続可能な社会を
作るためにですね
こう大きな発展もないやもずーっと続くていくそれよりはやっぱり新しいものなんか
このうちに身だ
生まれてきてからに生み出したいでもそれがその生み出すものがです我々今の我々をし
合わせてくれんもんかといったら多分まあそれは微妙とか違うんじゃないかと思うこの
ある種の宇宙と人間の関係なん美バランス
これ人が
宇宙と人文社会科学という学問の魅力だと思っています
ありがとうございました
[拍手]